comment faire cohabiter écoutez bien un
studio d'enregistrement de films
pornographiques et un élevage d'oies à
la campagne la question est au centre
d'une grande querelle dans une petite
commune des pyrénées orientales ne riez
pas la dame qui élève les oies reproche
aux acteurs de faire ça entre guillemets
comme des bêtes et de se promener à poil
fin de citation elle vient d'ailleurs de
porter plainte isabelle de lyon et
olivier combe qui ne nous ont peur de
rien et qui ne recule devant rien sont
allés enquêter sur place regardez bien
d'un côté un producteur de films x
j'entendais le bruit aux notes si
dérangeantes de l'autre trois mois et un
jour s'il s'est pas méfié des moins de
de
gaulle d'affolement c'est tout les oies
de la discorde appiah banlieue de
perpignan dans un quartier résidentiel
huit jours par mois un hôtel privé se
transforme en studio de films pornos les
oies se plaignent et les voisins avec
car le scénario évolue selon les
fantasmes et les comédiens et l'action
les mêmes parfois un peu loin et tournée
sur le thème
si les regards des voisins ne dérange
pas les acteurs l'écrivain allemand des
oies perturbe la prise de son la gêne
est réciproque beaucoup de femmes
familles à peine on leur demande
justement d'être très expressive au
niveau de la jouissance
mais si jamais réveillé les voisins ou à
noter le parti je ne cherche aucune
histoire à ce monsieur simplement la
tranquillité est moins de bruit et puis
qu'il fasse à cacher et puis qui
respecte mes quatre soit c'est tout une
plainte a été déposée auprès du
procureur de la république à lui de
clore cette prise d'émettre
c'est sérieux
[Musique]